-My first guest
is a talented actress,
a "New York Times"
best-selling author,
and a successful entrepreneur
as the founder
of The Honest Company.
Please welcome Jessica Alba!
-♪ Jessica Alba ♪
♪ You can't lie to me ♪
♪ 'Cause you're the founder
of The Honest Company ♪
♪ Jessica Alba ♪
♪ What can you not do? ♪
♪ My favorite actress
is raising babies, too ♪
-Jessica. Welcome. Welcome back.
-Thank you!
-Come on. Isn't it great
to hear an audience?
-Yes. I mean, it feels --
it feels like
it's closer to normal.
-Yeah, we're getting back there.
-It feels really good.
-Yeah, and it's only 58 people.
They sound like 8,000 people.
-No, seriously.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you again. Thank you
so much for coming in studio.
-Yeah, it's my pleasure.
-It means a lot to me
and to everybody out there.
I wanted to wish you
a happy belated birthday.
-Thank you.
-Happy birthday, bud!
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-How did you --
It was a big birthday, right?
-Yes. I turned 40.
-Wow! That's massive.
-Yeah, it's so weird 'cause,
like, when you're little,
you're like -- that age
just feels aggressive.
-Yeah.
-I don't know.
I don't know how else --
You're just like,
"That's a grown-ass person."
That is like,
"Yes, that is what that is."
And when you're here,
you're like...
"I guess this is what it is."
And it -- Yeah.
-And when you're here,
you're like,
"That's very young,
that person."
I'm like, "Well, I remember
when I was 40."
-Well, 'cause you're like --
you want to --
You know you have so much more
life out there to live,
but I feel like -- I don't know.
Everything is just
sort of, like, connecting
in a really cool way.
-Yeah.
Since you were on our show
last time, you went on this
hiking trip that I wanted
to ask you about because --
-Oh, geez.
-No, because I think
that you're in amazing shape.
You're healthy.
And wellness, that's your thing.
And I go, "Great."
-Yes.
-So I think hiking
would be right up your alley.
-Nope.
-Really?
-Definitely not.
-Wow. Now, explain it to me.
-It was a vegan hiking
detox situation.
-Uh-huh.
-And I didn't realize --
So, in my mind, I'm like,
"I'm going there
to do the healthy thing."
But, actually, you're
supposed to, like, eliminate
all the things
before you get there.
So, like, for a month, you
should stop drinking alcohol.
-[ Laughter ]
-And I was like, uh...
-Yeah, have you met
the quarantine?
-The night before, I was like,
"How many margaritas
can I get in?"
-You're like, "Oh, the detox
starts a month before the detox?
Oh, interesting."
-And then they're like,
"And you should eliminate meat,
you know, a week or two weeks."
I was, like, downing tacos
that morning...
-Wow!
-...with all the things on it.
-So then
you get to this place --
-So, I get there,
and I guess it just --
Oh, yeah, and you're supposed to
hike like six miles a day.
Who has time for that?
-Wait. So this is before
you go on the hike
you have to do the hike?
-All of these things.
You're supposed to walk.
Walk for like six miles a day.
Build yourself up.
I did not nary. None of it.
Zero.
-"Nary." [ Laughs ]
Nary a thing. I love "nary."
-But then we were on the hike,
and our first day,
we're halfway up.
We're like, "We don't know
if we can do this anymore."
And then a pack of solid,
solid senior citizens,
like, 80 to 90-year-old sen--
-Yeah, real seniors.
-They just, like,
boom, right past us.
-Booking.
And we're dying.
-Huffing and puffing.
And then they came,
and they lapped us.
They went to the top
and came back down.
And we still
hadn't quite made it up.
-Unbelievable! All right.
I want to check this out.
-I was -- Yeah -- Anyway.
One of those moments
where you're like,
"I might be failing at this.
Whatever this is,
this is not my thing."
-"Yeah. This is not my thing."
Exactly.
I'll tell you what is your
thing. The Honest Company.
Congratulations on this.
-Thank you.
-This is a giant thing.
We all --
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-I use it. I love it.
But this is a big deal.
You just went --
You rang the bell at NASDAQ,
and you went public
with your stock.
That's a giant thing
to happen for a business.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You worked your butt off, buddy.
You worked so hard.
How long have you been doing
that, The Honest Company?
-So I founded it nine years ago.
-Wow!
-And it's wild.
It's a dream come true.
I mean, it's --
You always think of, like --
You have this idea --
And can I really build
this ethical business that
stands for, like, human health
and thinking about the planet
and sustainability
and diversity and inclusion?
And can a company
that really has purpose do well
and be looked at in the business
world and taken seriously?
-Yeah. Nine years of work.
-Yeah.
-And it really paid off.
Your family was with you
when you rang the bell.
-Yeah.
-Was that emotional?
-Oh, my gosh. I was trying
to keep it together, but, yeah.
It's -- It's --
It was one of the most amazing
experiences,
especially to do that with --
you know, have my family with me
and my team.
And it was incredible.
-It's a big deal. Good for you.
Congratulations on that.
That's awesome
that you did that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Every time you come on,
I go, "What's the new thing?
What's the next thing?
What are we talking about?
Facemasks. What are we doing?"
But now you're like, "No.
I'm on to a new mission now."
-Yeah. So, we launched this new
Conscious Cleaning line.
And so we have an alternative
to the traditional
sort of harsh chemicals,
but it's a disinfecting spray.
So we have that.
We also have sanitizing wipes
that also use
our clean ingredients.
And then we have
three types of home cleaners
that you basically
reuse the bottle,
and it comes in refills,
and there's a concentrate.
So just, like, if you think
of all of the bottles
that go into landfill,
if a couple of choices
that all of us make can be more
thoughtful and more conscious,
then you're just going to
make a giant impact overall.
So I'm really excited that we
launched the Conscious Cleaning.
-I love that you're doing
all of this.
And a mom. And an actor.
You're fantastic and a great
guest to have on our show.
Please come back whenever.
You know we love you so much.
-Thank you.
-Jessica Alba, everybody.